President Trump says he was right the
first time about the protests in
Charlottesville his renewed criticism of
both sides is drawing an avalanche of
condemnation in a fire exchange with
reporters at Trump Tower yesterday the
president backed off of Monday statement
denouncing white supremacist groups
instead he repeated his original
response from Saturday and asked whether
left-wing counter-demonstration quote
have any semblance of guilt many
lawmakers including leading Republicans
quickly condemned his comments House
Speaker Paul Ryan wrote on Twitter we
must be clear white supremacy is
repulsive part of Senator Marco Rubio
tweeted mr. president you can't allow
white supremacist to share only part of
the blame in Arizona Senator John McCain
wrote there is no moral equivalency
between racists and Americans standing
up to defy hate and bigotry the
President of the United States should
say so but David Duke a former leader of
the Ku Klux Klan thanked the president
for his quote honesty and courage to
tell the truth about Charlottesville
Margaret Brennan is here in studio 57
she was at Trump Tower yesterday trying
to get a question to the president and
he was lobbying one back at you market
good morning good morning well president
Trump's remarks caught all the senior
officials by surprise as he put himself
in the politically complicated position
of appearing to defend the alt-right a
coalition of conservative and fringe
groups that back a white nationalist
agenda I think there's blame on both
sides and I have no doubt about it in a
tense exchange with reporters of
frustrated president Trump lashed out
doubling down on his initial equivocal
statement that both sides were to blame
for charlottesville violence you had a
group on one side that was bad and you
had a group on the other side that was
also very violent and nobody wants to
say that growing increasingly combative
with the press mr. Trump appeared to
defend the white nationalist groups that
organize the unite the right rally I've
condemned neo-nazis I've condemned many
different groups but not all of those
people were neo-nazis believe me not all
of those people were white supremacist
the president said the dispute centered
on the removal
of a Confederate statue so this week
it's robert e lee i noticed that
stonewall jackson's coming down I wonder
is it George Washington next week and is
it Thomas Jefferson the week after
but the president's frustration broke
through when we asked about Republican
Senator John McCain's call for him to
denounce attacks by the alt-right on
White House staff getting good health
care and he went on to say those on the
far left and the alt-right are equally
at fault what about the alt left that
came charging at the as you say the alt
right do they have any semblance of
guilt as the president spoke his new
chief of staff John Kelly the man
charged with bringing command and
control to the White House stood to the
side with his head down the limits to
Kelly's ability to keep the President on
message were laid bare as mr. Trump
defended his original statement on
Saturday's rally I brought it I brought
it which avoided condemning the white
supremacist groups who invoked his name
the first statement was a fine statement
but you don't make statements that
direct unless you know the fact he
condemned the driver who rammed his car
into counter protesters and killed 32
year-old Heather hire you can call it
terrorism you can call it murder you can
call it whatever you want
the driver of the car is a murderer and
what he did was a horrible horrible
inexcusable thing the White House is
asking allies to help defend mr. Trump
and we've seen the talking points they
urge supporters to say the president is
a voice for unity and calm and to say
that counter protesters were equally as
violent as the armed white nationalist
Margaret this press conference or QA was
completely unexpected but I want to ask
you about as the president doubled down
on this saying that some of the white
nationalists are very fine people
standing by his side were Gary cone and
Steve minuchin his Treasury Secretary
who are both Jewish does this his
statement yesterday put pressure on some
of these aides perhaps
about wer that about their future inside
the White House well this is as you say
people of great stature reputation with
long careers and you could see
particularly in Gary cones faces he kept
looking out at us at reporters to see
what our faces were doing what our
reaction was that he had a sense of what
was happening in that room because you
could you could feel how frustrated and
how angry the president was everyone was
really sort of taken aback by that but
what was also amazing was this quick
turnaround right afterwards the
president got in the elevator went up
Elaine Chao his transportation secretary
and Gary Cohen came right back down and
tried to answer questions about
infrastructure this is what it was
supposed to be about they are people
trying to get the president's
legislative agenda through and he took
them totally off script and put them in
this very odd position of having to
answer questions about neo Nazis they're
there to answer questions about roads
and bridges it was so difficult to watch
he is supporting a group of people that
were marching on Friday night saying
Jews will not replace us in very loud
tones and then it come out and seemed to
support them in some manner was very
very upsetting to a lot of people
watching that well it's it's something
that we're so used to a script being
stuck to from president saying there's
an ongoing investigation I don't want to
you know influence the outcome look we
condemn violence on both sides but as
you say this particular set of issues is
just so inflammatory that to go
off-script carries a lot of danger with
it thank you
Thank You Margaret